from the scary to the spooky to the
absolutely grotesque horror games come
in so many bits and pieces and i just
love them can i turn the audio off come
on
chances are if you're here then you do
too so please let me share my misery
with you with a list of the 10 horror
games you should scare yourself stupidly
easing into the list we have alan wake
remastered there's no better time than
now to visit the great pacific
northwestern fictional town bright falls
in this psychological horror thriller
you play as acclaimed writer alan wake
on a getaway with his wife to a small
town in hopes to kick his two-year
writer's block until he blacks out and
wakes up a week later to discover his
wife is missing and he's written an
entire novel that's become his
terrifying reality
sulking through the rural northwest
forest is filled with tense thrills and
controller crunching encounters that'll
spook you into becoming a flashlight
slinging shadow shooting new york times
best-selling author in no time package
that up with a mystery that unravels
like a serialized tv show and it's hard
to put the controller down even despite
the scares
at dead
of night
no game in recent memory has left me
trembling and wincing with my hand over
my eyes quite the way at dead of night
has in this game you play as a young
girl named maya back packing her way to
meet some friends before going to a
music festival where she stops by a
remote hotel that is run by this
delightfully charming psychopath jimmy
hall
nice to see so many
fresh
young faces
for a taste
it isn't long until your friends are
taken captive by jimmy and you are next
[Music]
as maya you have to roam around the
floors of the decrepit hotel gathering
clues and talking to ghost using a
spirit box to unravel jimmy's horrific
story is anyone there
and in the process avoid being cut by
him from around nearly every single
corner and boy does it suck
on the surface it can appear a bit campy
talking to ghosts old hotel fmv acting
and well jimmy just kind of looks like
he wandered in from a matt smith doctor
who costume contest with a bald cap on
but oh how looks can be deceiving
first off being chased by jimmy is
unrelenting psychological torment
in most horror games you're running from
an unstoppable threat that's chasing you
at all costs but in a dead of night it's
something of a cat and mouse game with
the tension of coming around every
corner feeling as though he's just
toying with you you'll catch him
stalking you ducking out of sight just
as you see him calling in the halls
sometimes even hiding in the dark as you
catch a glance of him as you rush by and
holy [ __ ] it is horrible
pair that up with the game's rigid
movement and every click is a white
knuckle gamble on whether you'll be
bonked by good old doofy jimmy
[Music]
additionally jimmy is not the only thing
there to terrify you but ghosts too
encountering a ghost are often jump
scares that sucked the air out of my
lungs and before i was able to catch my
breath i knew i'd have to slip back into
the halls where jimmy would call out to
me
it is
exhausting accompany this with its
narrow control scheme harrowing and
realistic environments considered sound
design and eerie tone and its atmosphere
is tremblingly very effective
[Music]
so much so that it seeped out into my
reality at times i found myself ain't
just even using elevators looking around
corners or in the night letting my
imagination get the better of me
um let's move on shall we
anyways maybe screaming and terror alone
isn't your back shouting with friends is
always more preferable besides you won't
have to deal with jimmy and phasmaphobia
but you'll have to still face a bunch of
ghosts the premise is simple you're a
ghost hunter like zack baggins from
ghost adventurers with a group of
friends or alone take gear like emf
readers spirit boxes uv lights
crucifixes and get ready to work as a
team to not capture the ghosts but
instead identify it phasma phobia's
horror is most effective and that it's
your job to lure the ghost out and
deliberately provoke it to cause havoc
in order to collect evidence which in
turn helps you and your team narrow down
what type of ghost it is while you do
have to hide from the ghost occasionally
the objective is essentially to piss it
off just like zack baggins you're like a
little come over here i'll just smack
you
stand right here i'll smack you whether
you're going alone or with friends
phasmaphobia is bound to give you a
wait
what was that
hello
okay
next game
okay so next on our list is resident
evil village which is really like a
horror themed amusement park with every
possible genre trope imaginable
stretched out through different themed
areas it's like a a caricature of the
entire genre with vampires werewolves
ghouls a witch swamp man
but not jimmy hall nowhere in sight in
this game
it's not the scariest in the series
resident evil 7 still helms that but
there's no denying one particular part
in village that will chip even at the
strongest wild house benaviento
no matter how prepared you are how many
times you've done this scene it just
never quite gets easier
[Music]
my god this cannot be happening uh
okay uh let's try let's just keep going
let's try this one yeah all right i spy
spooky mansion nothing's chasing you
here just you chasing some objects
that's right this is a chill horror
spooky game on the list
for when your heart gets high uh and you
just want to chill for a second but not
lose the spook entirely this is the way
to go look at this oh i could i could
deal with this oh my god
maybe i don't like scary games
why am i doing this
this is just my imagination not if this
is real
oh my god
i
think
jimmy
is in the next room no
just finish the video just finish the
video yep that'll be it that'll be fine
just get through it
you'll be fine and i'll leave you alone
delete olivia you'll never have to play
a scary game ever again just keep going
next game
amnesia yes uh they're all scary i knew
you probably knew that this was gonna be
on this list but look uh uh what would
horror games be today if not for the
original amnesia games
uh yeah and soma soma that's like
basically amnesia in space deadly
premonition look you don't have to love
it but i sure do and call phenomenon
goofiness aside that game has some truly
horrific [ __ ] in it i tell you uh fatal
frame spooky photography
horror stuff um nintendogs i [ __ ]
know um
lunch is ready
oh
okay uh
how long have you
been here like 10 minutes
alone
yeah
no no one else
no
oh
okay
thanks
[Applause]